when Earth is already suffering from
pollution and lack of enough food a
mysterious sphere starts proceeding
towards it a team of experts are sent
into space to investigate the sphere but
it claims itself as God Carla gray is a
talented woman whose family only
consists of her mother and her little
daughter the world is ending because of
not having enough resources due to
excessive increase in population and
NeverEnding pollution Carla also spends
days without having a single bite to eat
one day her mother tells her a story of
five people who only had food for three
two of them had to die after telling
this story Carla's mother disappeared
along with her granddaughter and Carla
was informed that they died Carla still
wonders if her mother sacrificed herself
for Carla or if it was just an accident
to distract herself from this
unfortunate incident Carla takes part in
a space mission a mysterious black
sphere is detected near Mars and it has
aroused curiosity in all human beings
the space station CEO Vance has sent a
team of experts to investigate theere
fear the mission is led by commander
senp and beside Carla the team also has
a few other members including a
middle-aged man named Ulf two young
Travelers tez and Shawn pronounced as
Sheen and an introverted man named C
rubben after 8 months of traveling in
hibernation the team gets up to prepare
their Landing Carla takes a moment to
remember about her late daughter and
mother afterward she gathers her
emotions because the team needs her
Carla notices that c seems a little
nervous so she offers to help him in
getting used to the spaceship
environment unfortunately C doesn't
respond much and keeps writing on his
blog all members head to the control
room to observe the current
circumstances it will take at least 16
hours for them to reach the sphere Mr
Vance calls to greet the team members
and inform them about the millions of
people who are looking forward to
knowing more about the mysterious sphere
before proceeding with the mission Vance
gives all of them a chance to talk with
their families through video chat as
Carla has no relatives Mr Vance himself
calls her as he considers Carla as
family because of the services she did
for the organization suddenly the
spaceship starts to shake and
communication with Earth is cut off
Carla rushes to the control room to see
what happens an extremely bright light
has covered the screen of the spaceship
as the system starts working again Carla
immediately checks where the light is
coming from it's the sphere a powerful
beam of light is emerging from the
sphere right on the spaceship it seems
like the sphere is alive and wants to
get closer to the spaceship Carla also
made makes another shocking discovery
that causes her to get Frozen in her
place Commander pu continuously asks
what happens so Carla finally speaks
there's a weird signal coming from the
sphere it's an audio message it consists
of only one word getting pronounced
endlessly the word deos which means God
all of the members get shocked to hear
this especially C he starts to panic and
calls it a sign to turn their spaceship
back to Earth Carla also believes that
they should pause this Mission till they
get further instructions from from Vance
but Commander pu suggests they shouldn't
stop as it's their first encounter with
an extraterrestrial intelligence which
came looking for them however he can't
confirm that the sphere is not dangerous
C interrupts the conversation and tells
everyone to prepare for their end as
they are going to be punished by duas
for their sins C has been hearing voices
since he woke up from hibernation
however pu is not willing to believe any
of this nonsense he wants his team to
act like Fearless explorers Ulf suggests
blowing up the sphere but pu warns him
not to even think of it after saigh
Carla also starts hearing voices but
considers it's just in her head Ulf
takes her to rest but Carla wants to
look for Sai who suddenly disappeared he
has gone into the deepest part of the
spaceship and put several cuts on his
body while chanting weird sentences tez
finds him first but he unexpectedly
attacks her with the knife when Carla
reaches there tez is already killed C
has completely lost his senses and also
threatens to kill Carla he believes that
they will die if they land on the sphere
so they must turn back the spaceship Ulf
tries to calm him down but Commander P
shoots C with his gun C dies on the spot
his and te's dead bodies are preserved
in the hibernation pod while the rest of
the team continue to prepare for their
Landing Carla can't get over what just
happened and advises pu to reconsider
his decision in response pu says that
Carla is getting scared for nothing
Vance has trusted her and billions of
people are looking forward to her
Discovery so she should behave like a
bra Explorer Carla turns to the camera
and reminds poel that Tiz just died and
C shouldn't be on board in the first
place they should stop making decisions
out of instinct Commander pu still
doesn't care and orders to land on the
sphere just a few minutes before their
Landing Carla notices some structures on
the sphere as the communication with
Earth is restored Carla asks Vance about
the structures but he has no idea either
but he has some shocking news similar
mysterious structures have also appeared
on Earth there are at least 10,000
thousand of them Vance believes it's all
connected to the sphere so it must be
investigated as soon as possible as the
spaceship lands on the sphere Commander
pu orders Ulf and Carla to get ready to
step outside but Shawn also wants to
join them they step out of the spaceship
but the sphere is covered in darkness
after investigating the ground Shawn
concludes that the sphere is made of an
unknown element they proceed towards the
structure which seems like a gate and
they use a flare gun to see how high it
is Carla notices an ancient symbol on
the gate which is known as the edge of
existence suddenly they notice a vivid
presence of an individual standing at
the gate a huge amount of signals are
released from the individual and the
Explorer's virtual assistant translates
them immediately the individual says
that she is speaking on behalf of the
Creator who is Alpha and Omega of all
existence the Creator wants to help
humans by giving them a choice they can
decide whether they want to enter the
gates or suffer the tragedy that will
happen when the sphere will collide with
the Earth these Gates will Unite them
with the Creator and give them Eternal
peace the individual chooses Carla to
explore what's on the other side of the
gate so she can convince other humans to
enter it Commander pu tells Carla to
enter the gate she finds a beautiful
place on the other side and gets
welcomed there by her late daughter
after a while Carla opens her eyes in
the spaceship Ulf says that she fell
unconscious after returning from the
gate so they carried her to the
spaceship Vance wants her to explain
what she experienced the whole world is
waiting for her answer Carla says that
she saw a golden landscape and a
beautiful city glittering in the
sunlight it looked like heaven Carla
doesn't tell them about meeting her
daughter she asks about Shawn but Paul
says that he died because he didn't put
on the suit properly Carla refuses to
believe that as she knows that an
experienced space Explorer like Shawn
can't make such a mistake once Po and
Vance leave Carla tells Ulf about seeing
her daughter the suspicious thing is
that pu knew that Carla was lying po
knows something more about this Fury but
he is not telling others po calls UL to
the control room and warns him not to
get too close with Carla thankfully UL
doesn't reveal what Carla told him they
prepare to get back to Earth but instead
of going to the hibernation pod Carla
breaks into pu's quarter she finds ul's
documents which reveals that he is not
an ordinary guy but a significant
officer who served for both Special Air
Corp and Elite core organizations Carla
grabs a gun and confronts UL why did he
hide his true identity and take part in
this Mission UL says he is here just to
maintain peace and knows nothing about
the fear Carla takes him to the control
room and threatens pual to reveal the
truth she saw Shaun's suit he was
murdered because he figured out a secret
about the sphar UL is brought here as a
Hitman to kill anyone who disrupts the
mission Vance also appears through a
hologram call and tells Carla to calm
down what she saw was Heaven and now she
can't prevent people from entering the
gates they have started doing it already
as the Earth has become a living hell
Carla turns to look at the Earth's
footage and pu uses this chance to try
snatching the gun the bullet shoots out
and hits Carla in Anger she shoots back
at pu who dies on the spot Ulf treats
her wounds and assures her that he
doesn't want to kill her he also didn't
know the truth behind the sphar it must
be something evil planned by people like
Vance Ulf wants to help Carla but the
ship is under the control of Vance they
have only one option they have to
separate the control room propulsion
from the rest of the ship and use it to
travel back to Earth UL knows the code
to make the spaceship do that however
there's one drawback the propulsion will
take 6 to 7 years to travel back to
Earth by that time the Earth would have
been destroyed by the sphere so there's
no home for Carla to return she suggests
they try to go back to the sphere and
destroy it Wulf agrees and goes to the
storage to get the bomb Carla returns to
the control room where she gets a call
from Vance as he knows Carla is going to
die anyway so he finally reveals the
truth the sphere is made up of a
self-replicating material called biomech
it is capable of building huge
structures according to the given design
really quickly it was built by no other
than Vance himself he did it to save the
Earth from Extinction the human
population has reached 21 billion
scientists conclude that within the next
30 years the earth will die out of
resources and the human race will be
wiped out so the officials decided to
sacrifice some people to save a few of
them otherwise everyone will die the
gates don't lead to heaven but death
Vance plans to let it keep going until
the population decreases to 6 billion
the prediction about the sphere
colliding with the Earth is also a lie
to scare the people it will be destroyed
by itself after getting near the Earth
and Vance will make people believe that
the sphar was just a warning from God
Carla still has a question how she heard
the voices of her family Vance smirks
and reveals another shocking truth
Carla's family died in an accident while
she was severely injured while she was
in coma a chip was implanted in her head
which can be used used to make Carla see
or hear things that aren't actually
happening the accident was done by Vance
too he was preparing Carla for 2 years
for this Mission so she can convince
others to enter the gates after hearing
this all Carla recalls the story her
mother used to tell it was about five
men with food for only three but they
didn't sacrifice anyone because all of
them deserve to find their own future
Vance is not saving Earth he is just a
Monster who is killing 15 billion people
before hanging up Vance orders the ship
to initiate self-destruction in 2
minutes Carla tells UL to reach the
propulsion so they separate it from the
spaceship UL tells her the code to do
that and advises her to leave without
him but Carla keeps waiting for him till
the last second she eventually gives up
and separates the propulsion while the
rest of the spaceship is completely
destroyed Carla assumes that she is
alone now but suddenly the gate opens
and Ulf steps in luckily he came back in
time he has also brought the bomb so
they can destroy the sphere once it's
gone the people will stop entering the
gates however the bomb has has to be
blasted manually on the surface of the
sphere Carla decides to do it together
with UL but as they are about to land on
the sphere Ulf closes the door before
her he wants to do it alone and let
Carla live so she can return to Earth
one day and tell others the truth about
the sphere Carla says an emotional
goodbye to Ulf and starts her journey
towards Earth which is going to take
almost 8 years meanwhile the sphere
explodes along with UL never trust
everything you see or hear focus on what
your heart feels your eyes may deceive
you but but your heart won't